grâce à un avion piloté par léopold
galli nous avons survolé visite de
briguer radiation implantée à colomiers
en bordure de l'aéroport de blagnac en
1960 qu'il n'y avait ici qu'un hangar de
montage général et d'essai en vol
aujourd'hui les activités de montendre
en s'étant déplacé vers colomiers lusine
comprend sur un domaine 24 hectares
trois hangars un bâtiment systèmes
électroniques
un hall d'assemblage de 203 m sur 90 les
effectifs de bragg et toulouse sont
passés de 1050 personnes en 1960 à 1650
fin 1970 dont 150 personnes encore l
usine de montaudran à colomiers le
régime de la journée continue est en
vigueur
de 7h30 à 16h45
le restaurant d'entreprise dans l'
architecture moderne n'exclut pas le
traditionnel peut être considéré comme
un exemple en son genre chaque jour
entre 11h30 et 12h45 15 cents repas sont
distribués en six services prix du repas
pour le personnel de francs 60
après la prise de contrôle de la société
par le groupe dassault en 1967
braga l'aviation a cependant garder son
autonomie et ses structures général la
dernière décennie a été marquée par des
directives de spécialisation de l' usine
de colomiers dans le montage général et
les essais de la viande série les essais
de prototypes se faisant à istres
dans le nouveau hall de 263 m sur 90 la
chaîne atlantique
le bréguet atlantique en 150 est un
appareil de reconnaissance en haute mer
et de lutte anti-sous-marine le seul
patrouilleurs au monde conçu pour ce
type de mission les études et les
fabrications ont été effectuées en vertu
d'un accord de coopération
internationale la série en cours porte
sur 40 appareils pour la france 20 pour
l'allemagne 18 pour l'italie 9 pour les
pays bas
115 mètres pour le décollage 65 m pour
l'atterrissage le break 1941
1941 on présente actuellement une idée
démontré depuis douze ans il représente
à mon avis encore à l'heure actuelle la
solution la plus économique au problème
de décollage et d'atterrissage cours
nous avons fabriqué quatre avions sont
en service dans l'armée de l'air
française
c'est tout pour le champ commercial
national
par contre mcdonnell aux états unis à
qui nous sommes liés par différents
accords de licence a poursuivi une
recherche fructueuse du marché américain
cette recherche se traduit par des
demandes de cotations de différentes
sociétés de transports
en somme le 941 n'est pas encore une
idée abandonnée occupant les deux tiers
du grand hall de montage général la
chaîne jaguar
le jaguar est un biréacteur d'école de
combat et d'appui tactique répondant aux
normes établies par les armées de l'air
française et britannique
il est construit en coopération avec la
british aircraft corporation
rappelons également la coopération rolls
royce turbomeca pour la définition et la
construction du moteur adour
trois actions sont prévues monoplace
pour l'appui tactique et l'aéronavale
biplace pour l'entraînement de
conception simple le jaguar est facile à
mettre en oeuvre et entretenir
l'accessibilité de ces différents
éléments et équipement est remarquable
le premier avion de série arrive au
stade final à colomiers son premier vol
est prévu pour juin prochain
sept prototypes dans les différentes
versions poursuivent actuellement des
essais en vol à istres et en grande
bretagne
il totalise déjà plus de 750 vols
le voici au terme de la visite est à
l'heure des conclusions le groupe
dassault breguet en construisant cette
usine en bordure de l'aéroport de
blagnac a donné notre équipe un outil
d'une rare efficacité
il nous appartient de valoriser cet
outil par une mise en oeuvre efficace
une première étape de cette mise en
oeuvre sera l'achèvement du déménagement
de notre vieille usine de montaudran
ce déménagement est accomplie à 90% il
sera achevé en juillet santé 11
du point de vue social est à prévoir que
les populations y travaillent avec nous
ce qu'on peut à peut drainer de la
banlieue est de toulouse vers la
banlieue ouest
une deuxième étape de cette mise en
oeuvre sera notre spécialisation en
usine de montage série des symboles
série cette spécialisation qui évitera
les dispersions d'efforts génératrice
d'inefficacité se traduiront chez nous
par un certain nombre de conversions de
métier sans incidence sur le niveau
d'emploi notre personnel a compris le
problème
il apporte son concours à cette
opération en conclusion finale disons
que nous sommes confiants dans l'avenir
à cause de notre usine neuve à cause de
nos avions de qualité
aujourd'hui l'atlantique et le jaguar
demain l'alpha jet